TO SHAPE THE COMPLAINT ITSELF.
I WOULD BE BELIEVE THAT?
DEVIN NUNES IS RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE OF ALL THIS, THE RANKING
REPUBLICAN ON THE INTEL
COMMITTEE AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
THE FORMER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
DO YOU BELIEVE THIS EXPLANATION?
>> NO.
THIS EXPLANATION?
NO.
>> Tucker: AND LOOKS FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE ON THE PEOPLE FROM
THE OUTSIDE LIKE ADAM SCHIFF'S
OFFICE GUIDED THIS COMPLAINT LIK
OFFICE GUIDED THIS COMPLAINT LIE
IT WAS A SET UP.
>> IT LOOKED LIKE HE KNEW
SOMETHING BEFORE HAND BECAUSE
THIS WAS IN THE PRESS AND THEN
UI AND STORIES WRITTEN BY GBS
REPORTERS AND THEN YOU
FAST-FORWARD AND HE HAD A COUPLE
OF TIMES THAT HE COULD HAVE TOLD
US IN PRIVATE THAT THIS HAD
HAPPENED.
NOTHING BUY A LOT MAKES HIM --
HE DIDN'T HAVE TO TELL US, BUT
HE CLEARLY GAVE NO INDICATION
THAT HE HAD EVER MET WITH THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER OR ANYBODY ON HIS
TEAM HAD EVER MET WITH THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
THAT'S THE REAL ISSUE HERE.
TWO OPPORTUNITIES -- TWO
OPPORTUNITIES BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS AND HE DIDN'T TELL US.
>> Tucker: THIS IS NOT ONE
AMONG MANY STORIES.
THIS IS THE BASIS FOR THE
IMPEACHMENT OF THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES.
IT'S NOT A SMALL THING, IT'S THE
OPPOSITE OF THAT.
HOW CAN ANY OF US HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THIS ISN'T A
PURE PARTISAN INVENTION?
>> IT IS AND IT'S NOT A REAL
IMPEACHMENT THE WAY THAT
IMPEACHMENT PROCESSES WORK, THE
OTHER TIME IT HAS BEEN USED.
I CAME FROM THE CAPITAL AND WE
HAD NINE HOURS OF AMBASSADOR, IF
YOU LISTEN TO THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, THIS WAS GOING TO BE THE
GUY THAT WAS GOING TO GIVE UP
ALL THE GOODS ON RUDY GIULIANI
BECAUSE THIS WAS THE SPECIAL
ENVOY TO UKRAINE ON BEHALF OF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
OF COURSE THEY WENT ON AND ON
AND ON.
WHY DID THEY KEEP GOING ON AND
ON?
THEY WEREN'T GETTING WHAT THEY
WANTED TO.
I CAME IN THERE AT THE END AND I
FELT HORRIBLE FOR THE MAN.
HE HAS BEEN A PUBLIC SERVANT AND
IS GETTING MARRIED IN A FEW
WEEKS AND HE WANTS THIS TO BE
DONE WITH SPIRIT HE WOULD KNOW
THAT BY NUMBER ONE, BEFORE HIS
TESTIMONY AND WHAT HAS LEAKED OT
TESTIMONY AND WHAT HAS LEAKED OE
TESTIMONY AND WHAT HAS LEAKED OR
TESTIMONY AND WHAT HAS LEAKED OS
TESTIMONY AND WHAT HAS LEAKED ON
TESTIMONY AND WHAT HAS LEAKED OE
TESTIMONY AND WHAT HAS LEAKED OT
TESTIMONY AND WHAT HAS LEAKED O.
>> Tucker: I HAVE TO ASK YOU,
YOU WERE IN CHARGE OF THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE CAA AND OTHER
INTEL AGENCIES AS THE HOUSE OF
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, DO
YOU FEEL THAT OUR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES ARE
PROPERLY OVERSEEN BY THE
CONGRESS?
DOES THE CONGRESS -- DOESN'T
DEMOCRACY HAVE CONTROL?
>> I THINK YOU COULD ARGUE OVER
THE FBI'S COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
AREA THAT STARTED THIS
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, NO.
A ZERO.
THE FBI HAS NOT COOPERATED
THROUGHOUT THIS INVESTIGATION.
PERHAPS WITH WHAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS DOING RUNNING THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE
BEGINNINGS OF THE RUSSIAN PROBE,
YES.
WITH THE CIA, I THINK THE
CHALLENGES HAVE BEEN -- WILL
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN PUSHING,
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THESE
AGENTS PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE
LINE.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT IN THE
FIELD.
THE CHALLENGE YOU HAVE IS THAT
THEY ARE WAY TOO MANY
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS AND
CONSULTANTS AND FORMER AGENTS
NOW PONTIFICATING ON NETWORKS
THAT LIVE HERE IN THE SWAMP.
LOOK, THERE IS A REASON TO HAVE
A SMALL COUNTRY OF FOLKS HERE,
AND I CAN'T GIVE THE NUMBER, BUT
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE ARE HERE IN THE SWAMP
WHICH IS NOT WHERE THEY
SHOULD BE.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE NOT.
THE MAJORITY?
REALLY?
>> I THINK IT WOULD BE THE
MAJORITY.
WHEN YOU TAKE THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE, CIA, DNI.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE HANGING
AROUND THE CAPITAL CITY.
>> LOBBYING FOR MORE MONEY FOR
THEIR PROGRAMS.
I TELL YOU, ONE THING THA PEOPLE
FORGET, I WAS THE WALL AND
IRONICALLY IN THE SPRING OF
16 WHEN THEY'RE OPENING THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLUDING WITH
RUSSIANS, I WENT OUT AND SAID
THE BIGGEST INTELLIGENCE WAS OUR
ABILITY TO UNDERSTAND
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S PLANS AND
INTENTIONS.
IN THE SPRING OF 2016 AND OF
COURSE YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DID TO
ME, THE PRESS CORPS IN THIS TOWN
AND THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Tucker: I WAS A SECE
>> Tucker: I WAS A SECT
>> Tucker: I WAS A SECR
>> Tucker: I WAS A SECS
>> Tucker: I WAS A SECI
>> Tucker: I WAS A SECN
>> Tucker: I WAS A SECS
>> Tucker: I WAS A SECY
>> Tucker: I WAS A SECA
>> Tucker: I WAS A SECL